el panorama pese a estos drásticos
números es muy alentador puesto que
estamos viendo una caída en los casos y
también una caída diaria de 4 a 5 por
ciento en las muertes y creemos que con
el plan de vacunación agresivo que está
llevando el gobierno del presidente de
bailén dentro de poco vamos a estar
nuevamente después de esta tormenta de
nieve que frena un poco la vacunación
vamos a estar cerca de los 3 millones de
vacunados diarios lo cual sería triplica
las expectativas de 100 millones de
vacunados en los primeros 100 días que
el presidente va a vivenciar y ha
propuesto así que creo que si bien los
números son muy altos el futuro creo que
es bueno y es mejor
bueno cuéntenos cómo se ha comportado la
mortalidad en el país desde que inició
la vacunación el pasado mes de diciembre
para cuándo podría eeuu a estar
aspirando a volver a la normalidad al
que se conocía antes de la pandemia la
normalidad antes de la pandemia tal vez
requiera mucho más tiempo que el control
de la pandemia
es posible que si llegamos si seguimos
si persistimos con este plan de
vacunación agresivo del gobierno de
bailén posiblemente para fines de la
primavera y para el verano tengamos una
gran proporción de la población vacunada
y el virus en caso de que no matase y
esperemos que sí que así lo sea va a
estar controlada a la normalidad tal vez
no vuelva hasta el 2022 ya anthony fauci
ha dicho que en realidad creemos que va
a haber que usar máscara y cierto
distanciamiento social inclusive hasta
comienzos del 2022 pero va a haber una
vida normal posiblemente ya para fines
del verano del 2021 pues agradecemos el
análisis de oscar cingolani desde emery